for a couple of weeks it was a lot of
fun people like toxic behavior people
like rooting for the bad guys is this uh
why does he look different because he's
back it's after after what after the
first video after our video yeah
but after his video master cheetah
bradley life was changed by his previous
video i mean yeah you admitted to some
crazy stuff you guys don't remember that
video i'll post a link below but holy
[ __ ] the things he was admitting to i
was like and you thought it was fake i
thought it was fake but the page
contacted us and be like no no that's
real we do real [ __ ] yeah i believe it's
real but i got into a lot of trouble
behind the video my life has literally
been ruined everybody saw it all my
friends all my family my boss saw the
video didn't want me there anymore i
lost my job behind the video child and
the baby mama saw the video she wants to
seek child support i have to go through
court i don't even have the money to go
through court and somebody sent my
girlfriend the video i was like that's
not me i'm not the same person that i
was when i did that video i'm in a
different mindset she wasn't going for
it she put me out same night she was
like you gotta leave you can't be here
anymore crying and being hysterical i
tried to get angry i tried to blame her
like well look at what you've done she
wasn't going for it i tried crying and i
cried some good tears too chris pause
you you tried to bamboozle her you know
he was like that's not me can i just
well then it was you you try to
manipulate her but the video told you
that you're a manipulator
game he's like these are some of the
these are some strategies i tried they
didn't work i tried to say it was her
fault i'm
he's consistent with it that's crazy i
try not to cry unless it's absolutely
necessary
necessary yeah i gotta go in i gotta go
you're
you're not changed bruh you listen to
yourself whenever she's going to kick me
out whenever she's fed up we got into a
fight in front of her family and it was
really bad and embarrassing for her so i
had to cry when we got home i'll cry in
any situation that's like my number one
defense just cry get them up off you
baby mama trip and cry [ __ ] want to
fight cry i would cry to get out of any
situation she said that i made a public
fool out of her i think that's honestly
my biggest problem with the whole
situation shouldn't care what other
people think she's going off of what
everybody else has to say instead of
just realizing that i have a good heart
i was cheating to protect her feelings
i'm doing it for her cheating saved my
relationship for years i would have left
that [ __ ] after a month if it had not
been for cheating
what have you learned you know what i
apologize i think this shit's fake now
that's not crazy the first time i
thought that now i'm like this [ __ ]
you gotta be like a sociopath
if this is real and they do exist yeah
you know god bless him this man is
talented
he's talented in a way or not
or he's just like that even if he's just
like that that's a talent cheating
really came in and saved the day because
when i was cheating i was happier my
girl was happier i'm meeting new women
i'm networking and as i'm more fulfilled
of a person that allows me to be a
better partner i get to come home happy
and refreshed you work your day job
monday through friday and then your side
check is the weekend that's how you get
refreshed for your relationship what if
you have to work seven days straight
with no break that's what a relationship
is you can't do everything with every
woman i'm with the big girl it's like we
can't go to universal studios and get on
the rides but i'm with um a smaller
chick maybe her credit's not right maybe
we can't live indoors together i take
best of both worlds i'm gonna go to
universal studios and ride the rides
with the pretty girl and i'm gonna live
with the girl who took better care of
her life because she had no other choice
she couldn't fit on the rides at
universal so she had to work hard at
keeping her credit up she can't fit in
the seat she's big she took everything
the car was driving she took that back
and now i'm like i got this little bitty
green car right now that i'm making work
i'm sleeping in the car i can't play
playstation at night anymore if my girl
was watching this babe i'm hungry i'm
tired i'm not getting good sleep my neck
hurt i realize cheating is bad and i
want to come home i'm sorry i'm sorry
for being a master cheater
let me come back home i'll be the master
boyfriend if i could go back and do
things differently i wouldn't cheat in
the end it was not worth it i'm no
longer the master cheater now i'm just
going to be a faithful man just one
woman and i'm happy about that so i'm
trying to start over i erased most of
the pictures off my instagram just gonna
start over find me a new girl and i'm
probably not going to cheat probably i'm
not it does look like you're out with a
girl last night
i mean
is that
it's not for the interview right
[Music]
this man is special bro
this man is talented this man is
talented you respect this real now this
man is super talented
like bro i gotta tell you between you
and me i'm never gonna stop my master
cheater stuff
i definitely would probably still cheat
i just wouldn't have done an interview
about it that's the only mistake that i
ever made that was not smart but i need
to swerve away from this persona for a
minute because it gave me so much [ __ ]
i'm never gonna stop and you can put
that in there i will end up living with
another woman but you got to wait for
things to happen in god's timing i feel
like god uses me to punish women who
aren't living according to their purpose
and he uses them to bless me i don't
know why god works the way he does press
pause
i'm embarrassed i think he's a sociopath
and he thinks this is funny
i think he's a sociopath who thinks this
is funny dude that's crazy shout out to
him though i'm a very spiritual person
one thing that is important to me is
being obedient to god and if he so
directs me to cheat on a woman and to
teach her a lesson i'm going to be
obedient and i'm going to do that i am
the master cheater
that's me
hey man listen oh
my god you know when something is so
egregious you can't even say nothing
about it
there's nothing to say it's like why
don't you have nothing to say negative
about murderers i'm like
because i think we all know that's wrong
what this [ __ ] did is clearly wrong but
hey man if you're dating a sociopath god
bless you it's like i was about to be
like yo maybe that's a video that says
that you know what he's gonna cheat
again or he's trying to win the person
he said oh he said all that good stuff
he said everything
as a commentary channel i'm dumbfounded
i got nothing i didn't i got nothing for
you i got nothing
i got nothing i wish i could
not the brightest cheater you also want
to do that and not have your reputation
be known everywhere but uh hey man that
shit's out there it's all over the
internet any girl you meet is going to
see that video so if you can still cheat
after that you've earned it you've run
the right yeah you've earned the right
if you're still boy to cheat when this
video fit evidence up there i got
nothing to say god i got nothing to say
it's like that pj washington thing
right oh yeah yeah right there was video
evidence of her saying i'll play an nba
player he got played ladies if you sleep
with this man after you've seen this
video and the videos out there you get
what you get
that's all for me [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign